they come in a game they're gonna make
an impact offensive defense know there's
so much time left and and Thaddeus Young
that time did it did a really bad thing
right there he went for the reach watch
right here he reaches right there
instead of just standing in front of
them being able to get to the basket we
should turn down a 3/4 track just hit a
four-point play here they come Kohi
six to shoot Colby trying to get by
Howard run him walk like right
if the Watts when Dale comes in and then
both these guys come in hit him and
again just the upper-body strength of
the white Howard goes right outside 92
foot
who's what
enjoy
he's been jumpers at the run back
knocked away police
but also drives to store
[Music]
inside Vista flying pass
there's LeBron he begins the back
[Applause]
[Music]
book dropdowns away and Anthony Davis
back to LeBron last play look at this
play set up perfectly an ATP hammers it
he knows that they're going to
double-team on the handoff so he gets
rolls to the rim and pressure up here
cook catch by layup
[Music]